okay to you who are other times in c4 on
the East Coast
um I'm Michele Dunne at the National
Health I'd like to welcome you to this
second talk mess of the UK guide to data
science
now last week and for the next few weeks
we're about computing the last week's
top Kovach who gave an overview of the
area this week will have a narrower
topic but still at a overview level a
high level 10,000 foot view of the of
the specific topic of workflows and
pipelines so we'll hear about what
scientific workflows and pipelines are
and how they will be useful or even
critical to science and big data
management our guest lecturer for today
is dr. Romy Amero who is the professor
or a professor of chemistry and
biochemistry at the University of
California San Diego her research is in
computational methods for drug discovery
where and at San Diego she oversees a
lab that does large scale simulations of
increasingly realistic biological
systems in order to investigate protein
function
she has received many awards including
the NIH new innovator award as well as a
peak a very prestigious
PK's award PK's stands for the
presidential Early Career Award for
scientists and engineers
dr. a Maryland many NIH grants is the
director of two very large NIH Awards
one is for the National biomedical
computation resource and another is for
the drug design discovery resource in
addition she
has received a bd2k r-25 award to build
an open educational resource which is a
couple of MOOCs as well as some a way of
discovering different materials so to
find out more about that you can go to
Roma's website you can also go to the
Big Data u website as well so please
join me in welcoming at dr. Amiya marrow
for this lecture today roomie
Thank You Michelle yes so I'm very happy
to give this lecture in the bd2k series
I'm going to be introducing a topic that
that is sort of close to my heart as a
biomedical researcher and that is the
topic of workflows and pipelines and
biomedical research so right just to
recap you just heard an introduction
from Michelle but I'm a professor of
chemistry and biochemistry at the
University of California San Diego
I direct NIH p41 multiscale modeling
resource called the National biomedical
computation resource I'll tell you a
little bit today about some of the
activities there I'm also the
co-director of the drug design data
resource which is another NIH drug
design methods development Community
Oriented resource and I think the main
thing that I want to get across in this
introduction slide is that I am a domain
scientist and as you can tell from my
background I do work obviously in data
science and it's very there's a lot many
very important aspects that impact what
we do I'm also a workflow convert and so
what I want to do in today's seminar is
because my understanding is we have a
pretty broad audience in terms of
attendees so I've tried to make this a
pretty general talk all about workflows
and pipelines so I'm gonna get a broad
introduction to workflows and pipelines
I'm gonna explain where they're both
useful and
well to what many of us are trying to do
in the biomedical research enterprise
I'll showcase by way of a specific
example in biomedical research how
workflows can be useful for what we're
doing and what we for enabling
reproducible results and I will also
introduce an example workflow tool that
we've developed at one of my resources
as well as discuss training
opportunities an additional material for
more learning beyond just the
introductory concepts that I'll speak to
today so I think probably most everyone
knows I'm sure that's called that it's
an extremely exciting time for computing
in biomedical research and that's really
for a number of reasons one is of course
that we've had a tremendous increase in
computing power and so what I'm showing
here is just the increase in compute
power sort of as a function of time and
I man that's been available on a
national supercomputing resources so the
supercomputing resources are these large
architectures that are available for
academic researchers in the United
States to to perform various types of
high-performance computing applications
and biomedical research has certainly
benefited significantly from these these
resources so this is just showing how in
the early 90s these first computing
resources came online they had about 12
CPUs and about every 4 to 5 years since
then we've increased our computing power
by an order of magnitude taking us to
2050 2060 2017 now actually we're really
right now in what we call this sustained
had a flock performance capabilities and
and that's brought to us by machines
like Titan at Oak Ridge also blue waters
at NCSA and something very critically
important has been actually the rise in
graphical processing unit technologies
or GPUs which have really brought
supercomputing to the desktop and so a
lot of the album
that we use in biomedical computing
research actually port very well to the
same architecture is used for to develop
great graphics for video games and so
this has really also been a game changer
in a number of ways for for biomedical
computing and then of course I think I'm
sure others in this series have
mentioned that there was recently
they've initiated the National strategic
computing initiative or the NSC I in
order to bring exascale computing into
reality hopefully you made within the
next 5 years or so so just a tremendous
increase in computing and that's really
infiltrated many many different aspects
of course not only in biomedical
research but for the scientific
enterprise generally speaking and of
course it's not just computing but it's
also data access to a number of
different types of data everything from
proteomics and genomics to increasing
amazing increasing data availability for
structural biology at numerous
resolutions including you know things
like from the structural structural data
for molecular component real Ike in the
PDB as well as macromolecular complexes
thanks to advances and direct detectors
with priority microscopy and so forth
and so in terms of what we can do in
biomedical research trying to bring
together all these different data
streams to create an address to create
new models for example either structural
models that might integrate proteomics
genomics high-resolution structural
biology to structural biology details as
well as cellular substructure to
determine with electron microscopy to
bring together to make a multi modal
multi scale model there's many many
examples of how data is infiltrating the
research enterprise and so together both
computing and data are really
transforming how we do research and so
when we think about how things used to
be I mean we're not just necessarily
doing one experiment at the bench right
I mean when we're posing
a problem or a question in biomedical
research it's much more than just one
set you know a typical or you know a
state-of-the-art example would be
starting with with electron microscopy
and all the terrific advances there in
terms of capabilities in resolution
for example with my complexes we start
with our data we collect the data at the
scope we then might we then ascend that
data for example at UC San Diego on a
high-speed network over to a
supercomputer and this I'm just using
this as an example here at San Diego
where we can take the data directly from
the microscopes to the Comets
supercomputer in order to do image
processing and then once we have that
data we bring its port in again through
a high-speed network from the
supercomputer into the lab and in the
lab we can build and interact with this
date these data sets using a variety of
software resources and develop models
and interrogate them we might add
additional components to those models
for example from a number of different
community data resources just there's
many different resources to possibly
pull from as you again build and
interrogate your model and then we might
send that that that new sort of
representation of the data or the the
method we might send that to back again
to the supercomputers for example to
blue waters and and then we have more
data that we process and return back and
can interact with in various ways it's
showing sort of a possibility of looking
at structures and sort of more than just
in three dimensions and so really where
we're at now is how we're experiment
simulation networking and expertise are
all combined into a super facility but
it's really sort of transforming how we
can do biomedical research and so the
challenge our one major challenge when
you think about sort of the complicated
end-to-end scientific discovery process
that a major challenge is the growing
complexity of the computation and data
that are required to solve these highly
specialized significant problems in
biomedical research and you know this
complex scientific enterprise really
brings a number of challenges but one
solution to the growing complexity is
the creation of pipelines and workflows
that are able to assist in the Assembly
of datasets as well as integrate what we
call domain-specific software codes that
are able to operate or execute on
various hardware systems or computing
architectures and to do so in a way that
is robust usable and reproducible and
this is really where this is really
what's going to be demanded for what is
currently in a minute and will continue
to be to be demanded for successful
biomedical research projects okay so
what is a scientific workflow so
scientific workflows emerged as an
answer to the need to combine multiple
data and computing components in an
automated fashion so a scientific
workflow is really basically just a
series of different computational steps
that scientists use to to generate
results okay and this may involve
accessing multiple different
applications scientific applications and
different databases as I mentioned also
could involve the processing of data
most frequently it does using
computationally intensive jobs on
various types of computing platforms and
I'll tell you more about those with some
specific examples so the idea is just
that it's capturing these scientific
workflows are really capturing again
sort of the the complicated many many
step end-to-end experiment ideally that
is that represents a scientific result
okay and so even backing off sort of
getting more simple about it so really
what is a workflow and so we use there's
workflows everywhere
not just in biomedical research so if we
just think about when we're trying to
cook something so I think one analogy
that I sort of like when I'm trying to
introduce the concept of workflows and
pipelines to be very introductory about
it just to think about how one cooks or
how one basically yeah so when you're
trying to create a recipe and cook food
you have to basically there's many steps
that you're doing you're shopping you're
preparing the food you're cooking it and
you're enjoying it eating it and you're
also storing it and so each of these
steps has it takes a certain amount of
time and it's essentially a workflow
some of those tasks that have to be
performed might be enjoyable as sort of
as illustrated here with the sort of the
phase text some of them might be more
tedious or chore like and so one example
is like we're making pasta this evening
so there's all these different things
that we have to do there's it starting
with the shopping for ingredients you
can see like the raw ingredients on the
left
you then have to prepare the different
ingredients maybe by chopping and dicing
etc you then have to cook it and there
might be multiple things that you need
to cook and then ultimately you can
serve it eat it and then store it so
these are all different steps that sort
of you know represent not about medical
research workflow I'll get to that but
just sort of the overall concept and so
each of these steps they take place in a
certain order and they have a certain
time requirement and some of these
things need to happen at the same time
as others some of them needs to be
staged some things can happen in
parallel others need to happen in series
so you know this is an example that
we're all familiar with so we can think
about some workflows in this context
even for biomedical research and so one
thing that we might want one way that
workflows can be applicable here is if
you want to speed things up so if you're
cooking for example there are things
that time management can become very
important if you want to actually come
up with a result or a food or cooked
product at
their time right so time management is
important and you can take advantage of
this downtime when you're working on one
element of the recipe you can then shift
your attention to another while
something is allowed for example the
pasta is boiling and so these recipes
can be modified and they can be
optimized and also similarly analogously
when if you have more than one cook so
can particular jobs be farmed out to
different people or in this case of
automated workflows it's two different
hardware architectures and what can be
done at different times or the same
times with with multiple participants
and so one example again going back to
cooking so if we when we're just
starting this let's say that we have our
vegetables and this is something so we
can sort these vegetables and if we have
multiple cooks each cook can basically
be chopping and doing and doing the work
on a certain set of the vegetables and
then now this would be equivalent to a
math function where the input is are the
veggies and the chopping is what we
would call a user-defined function and
the output of this operation would be
chopped groups of each kind of veggies
this is sort of the food equivalent to
math function now we have these outputs
of these different piles of veggies and
we can think about now we want to bring
them together so we have all these
different piles we want to bring them
together we bring the tomatoes together
the peppers together the onions together
this is like similar to what we call the
reduce step so here now the input is
having chopped batches of vegetables for
each type and the equivalent
user-defined function would be to
combine these vegetables basically based
on type so we can sort them and then the
output is a bowl of vegetables per
veggie kind so we can again these are
sort of the the sort of the food
analogies of developing functions and
and how we can sort of parse out
different jobs to different people in
order to
optimize and then you think about when
you want to make something more xi now
we're not just doing pasta we want to
make a Thanksgiving dinner we have many
many dishes to make we may have many
helping participants each you know
recipe and so forth has different
preparation time cooking time cooling
time etc and so as a chef for as
somebody who's organizing this you have
to think about all these things when you
start cooking
what cetera and so this is an example of
how we already use wuerffel's and are
really familiar with them is sort of our
in our just daily life and now I'm gonna
give you some more concrete examples of
how these workflows can be useful how
workflows can also be useful in science
and so one exists so workflows can take
a number of different forms they can be
for example very simple pipelines where
one example is that you have data discs
so you choose you can read it you can
you can then create a function that
basically does a multiple sequence
alignment for you and then it outputs
that alignment into something that does
a phylogenetic analysis and then you can
output that out it can transfer the
output of the phylogenetic analysis into
something that for you where you can
actually visualize it with for example
using using trees and so forth workflows
can also integrate components to analyze
to analyze local data so this is an
example of of a workflow drawn in Kepler
which I'll tell you more about it for
computational flow cytometry data
analysis so here again this starts to
get a little more complicated but
basically different components and
different data components can actually
come together to to participate in the
analysis and data that that's held
locally we can all
youth pipelines and workflows to
integrate different many different
online tools and several different kinds
of databases using complex programming
structures so here's an example of a
workflow that's doing some microarray
analysis to identify a new candidate
target chains in here that we start with
microarray data we do a clustering
analysis we can identify the genes we
can get then get the sequence retrieval
we send that back out to the NCBI class
search it brings back other genomic
sequences and then we can look for
things like promoters and promoter model
generators in order to generate a
consensus sequence which we put back
onto the blast search and then again to
finally identify candidate target genes
so it's a way this is a more sort of
elaborate example of how workflows can
be used to integrate a number of
different online tools as well as online
databases in order to help facilitate
biomedical research workflows can also
have concurrent analysis and data
management steps that actually are
distributed to different computing
platforms and so this is an example that
I will speak more much more about when I
give a great example but here we can
actually what this workflow is doing is
actually one of the certain of what we
call actors or modules in this workflow
is actually being used to to distribute
or to sort of spawn out many different
jobs in parallel on an HPC platform and
then the analysis on each of those can
come back asynchronously or
synchronously in order to to do to sort
of to determine the results of the jobs
of course workflows can also integrate
cloud resources so they can tie into and
connect to not just local data but data
that can be in the cloud or other places
so overall biomedical
workflows allow us to assemble complex
processes easily transparently access
different computing resources which is
increasingly important as computing
enters warm or illness biomedical
research Enterprise it us to in an
automated and more rigorous fashion
incorporate multiple software tools and
I'll talk more about also by that so
important in again in the example I'll
show you and then they also help enable
reproducibility which of course we all
know is a major challenge I mean for
science in general but also for
biomedical research how we can ensure
that when we have one student or
multiple students working on a project
that then when those students leave
protocols are being followed correctly
and that we really knew how we generated
the model but in a very specific in a
specific enough way that it's really
truly reproducible and of course the
best research workflows will really
build around a community development
model this is something that I think
many fields are now many subfields
within biomedical research are really
embracing and that's the idea that so I
can develop workflows in my lab and
share them very easily with colleagues
and as a community and we can use each
other's efforts to build again and use
these sort of more elaborate
reproducible arket frameworks for
science and so there are many scientific
workflow systems as one can imagine this
is something that people have been
working on for at least two decades and
so one of the earliest scientific
workflow systems was something called
discovery in that and then there were
home rings of Triana Pegasus cavern of
pipeline toilet coming on in the early
2009 is another very popular workflow
system we have this trails gene patterns
you can see sort of that aloo
these through about 2010 and what I'm
going to mostly talk about today in the
concrete examples is a workflow system
called Kepler this is again a very
popular common workflow framework it has
a diverse library of scientific
components and use cases it allows
transparent support for multiple
workflow engines so you can actually
connect so even within a Kepler workflow
you can actually call other workflow
systems for example like 9 in order to
execute an intent process and it's used
by many communities not just in
biomedical research but also with fire
detection and all sorts so it's it's
been it's been a useful community
development tool so that's the one that
I mostly focus on today but I just also
mentioned of course that there are many
different programs a lot of them have
strengths and weaknesses
you know there's I'm sure many other
learning opportunities if you want to
dig in on the details of these other
workflow systems right so so how do I
use workflows and how did I come to sort
of seeing a light with how useful they
can be and how important they actually
are to the scientific enterprise so this
example I'm going to tell you about is
one that's in my domain of expertise
which is computer aided drug discovery
so the work that I do in my lab and that
we do so many resources actually
involves the computational modeling of
atomic level systems and so we'd like to
think of one of the major approaches
that we use there's something called
molecular dynamics simulations and I'm
showing here a picture of a
computational microscope so this was a
sort of a phrase coined by Colton which
basically it's sort of we're trying to
use these computers to H PC computers
mainly but now actually it's involved in
to using also GPU architectures we're
trying to use these methods to gain
additional insight
to these molecular systems that we
sometimes cannot access with experiments
and so what this what these simulations
involve so basically we're representing
all the atoms of our system we remember
that system at the atomic level and so
we define what we call a potential
function which you can see there so
every two atoms that are connected form
a bond and every three ends are
connected form an angle every four atoms
are that he knows the portions in each
of these terms each of these elements of
the system actually has a term in a
potential function and then we're
basically using physics we're just
simply integrating Newton's equation of
motion over time in order to build up a
dynamical trajectory of the
time-dependent dynamics of our system so
we're basically representing this these
molecular level systems numerically and
and trying to determine sort of there's
the wiggling and jiggling of atoms if
you will and so these experiments use a
number of different community developed
tools like Nandi amber many different
tools actually and the engine that this
microscope runs on are basically the
supercomputing platforms and and now
requesting units and also sometimes
local desktops and so forth but they can
run in many places so one of the major
goals was that we had in my lab was to
try to use simulation in early stage
drug discovery and when I'm showing on
the left is an old like napkin sketch
from actually when I was a postdoc and
just sort of like walking through how we
could use the output of the simulations
which as I mentioned is just sort of the
wiggling and jiggling or the
time-dependent dynamics how we could use
this in drunkest in computer aided drug
design and so it's really you can see
this is sort of like chicken scratch and
over the course of some years and we
were able to actually develop methods
that would be gainfully used to
incorporate simulation in your discovery
and so what that would mean
so you can see that I'm sort of
advancing the the concept here of the
work flow is advancing and this is sort
of like I think a normal wave for it's a
very sort of natural normal way for
scientific methods and projects to
involved first you start with an idea
that's literally a sketch on the back of
a napkin and you know you work on that
you keep working on it and then you get
the first prototype and then you know
you can continue to elaborate and
ultimately what I'll show you many
slides down the road is that these this
we've gone from basically the napkins
type drawing to really a hardened
workflow product and so so why do we
care so just in case there are some
scientists out there you know I want to
give you a little bit of science in
addition to the computing so one
successful example of this is this
involves p53 which is the burning of the
genome so p53 is a protein that's a
transcription factor that's it's mutated
and over 50% of all human cancers and so
it's it's it's a molecule that senses is
basically when when the cell has some
type of damage like DNA breaks or or UV
radiation p53 should sense that damage
and then unregulated pathways related to
programmed cell death like rosa brass
may pop ptosis and prevention
evangelizes and so what happens in over
50% of human cancers is that p53 is
mutated and it's inactive and so these
tumors just proliferate and so on we
were very interested in trying to
understand what was going on there how
these how the destabilization worked etc
and a long-standing dream of cancer
biologists actually was to try to
basically reactivate that cancerous or
inactive p53 with small molecules and so
the idea would be that you would have a
cancer medium that has this inactive p53
you would buy some drug to it and he
would reactivate it and then those cells
that formerly were just proliferating
and metastasizing that they would
actually that they would reengage their
program cell death and they can die and
so there were none
compounds that have been found over the
years after about 20 20 years of
research they had been a handful of
compounds they didn't know exactly how
they worked and so on we and molecular
dynamics simulations of this target in
order to try to figure out again we're
interested in looking at the dynamics
because we had known that actually it
was quite a flexible protein so this is
the output of a molecular dynamic
simulation you can see sort of all the
atoms wiggling and jiggling and what I
want to bring your attention to is this
area in the middle where we have a I
don't know if you can see my cursor but
there's a cysteine residue here and a
pocket where you see a lot of mobility
okay and so what was really interesting
from a scientific perspective was that
if you looked at the PDB database
there's over 100 different structures
and they all have the same sort of
architecture around that particular
cysteine which is actually it's sort of
like tucked away and back sort of a
closed pocket and so what we see in the
computational simulations is actually an
open the formation of an open pocket
around this residue and this was very
intriguing because if we found this new
site and we also saw that it might
perhaps actually be druggable so we did
we performed small molecule docking into
that site and basically using sort of
the works so here's sort of just a
sketch of the workflow for virtual
screening where we can take these
protein or receptor structures and this
could be coming from the PDB database
with x-ray crystallography it could also
be simulation data from the molecular
dynamic simulations we have another
database of ligands in this example
we're using the NCI diversity set we
bring them together using Auto doctrina
so this is another procedural operation
we then do what's called post processing
and then we pass our predictions to the
experiment to our experimental
collaborators for testing with this
workflow we were able to find one
reactivation molecule called stick two
Gasset and our collaborators showed that
it was dependent cancer cells but one of
the really interesting things also is
that in addition to
a new compound we were able to
rationalize the mechanism of action for
one of the formerly discovered compounds
it's actually in clinical trials so this
is really exciting then we wanted to
scale it up and bikes feeling up we
really wanted to be able to to screen
against many many more compounds and
also to do sort of much more
sophisticated post-processing with
regard to ranking of compounds and one
way this was enabled was through through
workflows and so with this sort of more
automated pipeline so this I'll just
call it pipeline because it's really
just showing sort of like the the
procedural steps of what we're doing we
were able to discover more many more
compounds in a very short amount of time
they spent six months than in all the
research efforts of the previous 20
years combined so it was you know once
we were able to scale it and with a good
model we rated the discovery really sort
of took off and so we what we were able
to do was really go from what was just a
chicken scratch pipe dream to sort of a
pipeline to now a scalable automated
workflow and so so what does that mean
so when we were doing these experiments
that I was telling you about here as
this is really as many people in
research will do and in computational
biomedical research I'm tripping in many
other fields also again when you're
developing a prototype very often what
happens is you have a postdoc or a
student who has a set of scripts and
they're running these scripts and
sometimes these scripts can be quite
elaborate but there's many many steps
involved in this workflow everything
from selection of the structures that
you're inputting into MD to the creation
of the molecular dynamics model running
of the trajectories selecting the
structures how you process the ligands
how you're doing the docking all of the
you know there's so many things that one
really needs to keep track of and you
know we do our best I think everybody
all by
researchers tried to do their best in
terms of keeping very careful lab notes
digital notebook saving the scripts and
so on and so forth and that gets us
pretty far but it still has significant
it still has significant limitations and
I'll talk about some of those
limitations and how workflows can help
us get around those so what we did was
actually to develop a using the Kepler
workflow system we were able to develop
a scalable automated workflow so we
would basically have we would be able to
in this one example we would have a
different we would have a all those
small molecules that we wanted to screen
against we put those in a directory and
this catholic flow would see this
directory it would go into the contents
and then actually perform a series of
steps that would what we call
parameterize the ligands which is
getting them ready for molecular
dynamics we can then simulate them and
then do processing and each one of these
so this little box here this ligand
parameterization is actually represented
by if you actually dig into this one
task it's actually many subtasks right
and this is really how it is for many
different steps in biomedical research
so when we take instead of using scripts
for this antechamber step in this
Gaussian step and so forth we can
actually encode it into a workflow such
that all we have to do is have a
directory of ligands and then everything
else just flows as the output finishes
it flows to the next and close to the
next and there's everything about it is
tracked again I'll tell you more about
that so all the software versions all of
all of like when you you actually ran
the jobs all the library dependencies it
can all be tracked to something called
provenance and so when we put when we
recapitulate these very complex
end-to-end experiments into these
automated workflows it brings tremendous
benefit including increased reuse
because it's much easier generally
speaking for a new student or postdoc to
to pick up and
run these automated workflows if they
don't have to stitch together a bunch of
sort of loose scripts
it increases reproducibility because
we've now really tracked everything and
all the dependencies with products it
helps a scale execution both of the
problem and the solution so I'll talk a
little bit more about scaling of
execution so that just essentially means
that we can we can more easily connect
to different computing resources in
order to carry out the job and it makes
it easy to compare methods so if you
just want to really change only one
thing you can just go in and change one
parameter inside one box and rerun it
and compare and it also makes it
significantly easier to train students
because now they see when they sit down
for the first time they can see the
whole pipeline and digging on each
module in a way that is simplified and
so one of just one of the steps that we
carried out in the whole and the very
complicated end-to-end process of small
molecule discovery one of the processes
as I mentioned was just running at
molecular dynamic simulations and so
we've worked to develop again a workflow
tool using Kepler that just carries out
amber what we call Amber molecular
dynamics so amber is an MD engine that's
available broadly to the community and
we've developed now a workflow tool that
just allows people to carry out research
quality molecular dynamics simulations
using amber GPU processing technology
and the Kepler workflow system and so
these are again a sort of a very high
level representation of different steps
that we have to do in order to carry out
their dynamics and and so if we look in
this one step of something we call
minimization if you actually zoom into
this minimization box there's many steps
it's not just one step for minimization
there's actually five different
minimization steps and so what this tool
does again is in an automated fashion
sort of feed drunk as as the first
minimization step finishes have been the
output feeds into the second step and so
on and so forth and then the outputs
form is a
go to a stage we call heating and then
to a collaboration and again in a
collaboration you can see it's multi
stage and then when we get to production
one interesting thing here is that you
see that there's all these different
little outputs so it's going basically
when we go to production instead of just
running on one GPU we actually scale it
out to multiple GPUs in parallel and so
this this workflow tool basically allows
researchers to do that very very easily
okay and then so it's also it also has
sort of a graphical user interface for
users and so again sort of the Hulk at
the molecular dynamics workflow you can
actually users can go in to each of
these little boxes and at the base level
they can go in and edit the key
parameters different parameters can be
exposed or hidden depending on you know
some parameters if it's people know in
various programs we basically maybe
never change others you have to change
depending on your system
so this can be configured so we
configured it for molecular dynamics
using sort of best practices for the
community but this can be different
levels of detail can be hidden or
revealed depending on depending on the
application and then we can in terms of
where these where the simulations
actually run they have different options
you can have local execution options you
can run on a cluster and a local cluster
or you can also port out to for example
the exceed computing resources like
Gordon or comet and so so this sort of
so the this the the gray circle here is
just sort of showing all the different
types of energy heterogeneous computing
resources that these workflows can
connect to and that includes for example
operating in the Amazon Cloud and even
within one workflow you can have many
different computational architectures
engaged that's one of the advantage
if Kepler is that if I have one step
that needs to run on my local GPU it can
just do that but can also route to NSF
resources or again the cloud or any sort
of computing architecture so we can have
multiple architectures engaged within
one single workflow okay so so we're
getting to the sort of forty minutes in
so how does one even start
conceptualizing a computational workflow
well in general sort of we would advise
to start with the workflow as a black
box and so just treat the whole workflow
as a black box and you'd have to think
of what is the use case and application
so what is the real science question
that this workflow is solving right so
you're gonna have here some input data
and then you have some process and this
you know it's just shown as one giant
black box but it's met sometimes many
many steps and then you have to think
about what your output is going to be
and then you have to conceptualize then
you really need to sort of dig into well
what are my steps right so in terms of
cooking this is things like you know if
I'm working on the PI I have two that
are a big big turkey make the side
dishes so for this would be for
Thanksgiving dinner all the things you
need to do for a scientific application
you know this might be things like
sequence alignment etc and so you
basically treat each step like a
workflow like a mini workflow so you
want to basically try to reach what we
would call I guess an atomic functional
step right so so you really you mean you
think about all these things you have to
find the data access the data maybe you
have to move the data and then once you
have the data it has to be cleaned
possibly integrated maybe you need to
divide it up or process it and then you
get into actually running the jobs if
you have like for example simulations
you are processing the generating data
processing data and analyzing data and
then you get into data interpretation
and so forth where you're going to
interpret the results coming back to
visualization
and so this you know going back to our
cooking analogy is sort of we have the
shopping stage the preparing stage the
cooking stage of the story stage and so
questions that one wants to ask is
definitely where and how do you get the
data in what format is the data in how
can you actually integrate or subset
data sets and then of course how you
analyze the data
what is the analysis function what are
the different parameters that are needed
to customize each step etc and I will
say you know that when you have an end
to end when you have a complex workflow
or experiment it is like you know it's
challenging to do this and it requires a
lot of time and a lot of thought but
ultimately this is the kind of things
that will enable truly sort of
reproducible science and I think one of
the great things about workflows is that
once you do this work with really
analyzing and this detail and putting
things together and standardizing the
process the data and the process you
then have a tool and that also becomes
that that that's sort of
conceptualization of the data itself is
actually very valuable in terms of the
step for searching for the data of
course what you need to you need to sort
of know what you're looking for it first
so different data formats and how you
know sort of the meaning of the data how
it actually scientifically and
conceptually relates to the analysis
that you're doing and then it helps if
you of course that you it for you to
know exactly where you need to find that
data so where to find what you're
looking for and here I'm sure there will
be other talks in the series where some
of these data sources are discussed in
more detail but there's many searchable
data archives and repositories and
people are working very hard to make
sure these are standardized with correct
date ontology and metadata standards and
so forth and they can any way the data
could also for example be coming from
your own sensor networks or other
scientific instruments even it just in
your own lab another important component
that needs to be considered in general
the scientific enterprise but also with
workflow
do you have to move data sometimes you
do need to move data and then depending
on how big it is that can be a problem
and maybe you need to come up with
different ways to access the data since
you don't have to move it but in any
case this is just to note that moving
data can sometimes of course be a big
challenge especially for very large data
sets and it's something to think about
and to try to avoid I would say at all
costs if you can help it so there's
various different data access
technologies also that can be used if
data moving is needed again I guess like
sort of already covered this but we have
the ability what are the great things
about developing these workflows is that
once you have them developed it's the
same coupler it's actually not that
difficult to change where you are
executing the jobs either the data
generation jobs with the analysis of
processing and so you can move around to
different computing resources depending
on the requirements of your job and so
some for example some steps maybe more
memory intensive some maybe more compute
intensive some Mayport very well two
GPUs you can be flexible about that and
you should be so that you can really
gainfully take advantage of as much so
you can get as much advantage as you can
of the different resources and then as I
mentioned once you do the work of
building the workflow you build it once
and it is a lot of work to build it but
then you can run it many times and you
have terrific possibilities for reuse so
the state hopefully the same workflow
will support your experimental
computational experimental work and
dynamic scalability on many different
platforms and the scalability can be
based on a number of different sort of
data features like data volume and
velocity this could change depending on
depending on those aspects of it maybe
you might need to change something about
the modeling based on different
optimization criteria and then also of
course these workflows once you build
them you can run them many times
you can also alter it based on changes
in network storage and computing
availability and so these are tweaks
that can be made and then one of my
favorite parts really of the workflows I
have to say is the saving and sharing of
the reports and final products with your
team and collaborators and with the
broader community right so computational
data science is right in the middle sort
of bridging the gap between the data
that is generated and really the key
scientific insight and so to bringing
everything together in a workflow in a
scalable automated workflow like I
showed you with Kepler is something that
can be tremendously powerful and so you
know I think another sort of aspect of
this is that people should they can and
they should use whatever favorite tools
or programs you need to answer the
question there's no reason to deal that
you that you need to be limited I think
really the possibilities are almost
endless in terms of different
possibilities to enumerate it's in your
own scientific domain and then one of
you know the great thing is that the
process itself is shareable so you have
when you build these work clothes they
themselves are their own sort of data
structure and you can exchange them
communities of course are working very
hard to standardize that again as I
mentioned multiple times they're
scalable and it helps these workflows
also help enable really sort of
accountable science right so again sort
of not to beat a dead horse I guess what
I would say
but these scientific experiments
involved many different kinds of data
coming from different sources and
there's different versions this is the
other thing that has driven us crazy is
how you know you can
run a particular program for example
adopting program one day on one
particular architecture and then there's
some updates that's made and now it's
version five point seven instead of four
point two and maybe it didn't break any
on the scripts that you use this input
but it maybe it changed the results
because of something and you know if
possible sometimes that trainees and
researchers don't necessarily you know
know the fine fine detail of what's
going on especially for people who are
domain scientists and who are putting to
pulling together you know twenty
different tools in one biomedical
experiment and so one of the great
things about these workflows is that a
lot of that versioning of dependencies
and everything it's very can be reported
through something called provenance and
tracked and then and report it and story
so that you people really know exactly
you know what was happening at what
given time and you can we follow that
data flow and of course so that's just
you know on the data and execution side
but you can really sort of very clearly
see and document what processes ran in
which order which were you know which
steps actually depended on the output
for the previous step which could just
run in parallel separately which
libraries were used and and also who
generated what so if you have
collaborators it's a very good way to
sort of share to share everything and so
provenance is something that I know has
been talked about already more
technically for sure in the bd2k series
but basically for those who haven't
heard it Providence basically is
something that helps tremendously with
what we call research accountability and
reproducibility
it's basically according to Wikipedia
they would define it as the chronology
of ownership custody or location of a
historical object so when we think about
provenance in terms of workflows this is
really sort of like like a digital
notebook but on steroids it contains
lots of it contain actually can contain
different information depending on what
you said
so it can be configured to retain
particular aspects of the experiment
that you think are important but it can
capture everything inputs outputs
intermediate results all the work the
parameters and details of the different
components of the workflows so all those
different actors or boxes which I showed
you all the steps how the steps are
linked together all the different
parameters this can be this can actually
be reported in with data provenance or
with these provenance elements and this
is useful because it keeps the
association it retains the association
of results of a particular workflow to
processes it also makes it easier to
validate and regenerate results and
processes because you know exactly how
you got them in the first place it's
much more easy it's much easier to
compare different workflow versions do
parameter optimizations at cetera and
sometimes some of these programs
actually allow you to do sort of
intelligent or facilitated reruns and
failure recovery so different questions
you can ask with provenance or different
questions that are answered with
provenance for example you can find out
how long did this particular workflow
brah take what parameter values were
used what different components or
processes or actors does the workflow
have how long does one particular actor
take so how long does one step where's
my bottleneck and what what workflows
did a specific user run on a given date
these are all questions that work
together and so again there's many
reasons why you might want to share work
clothes for example if you're doing
collaborative research if you want to
just inform people of progress or
formalize application development etc
and also for publications I mean I think
one of the also movements that we're
trying to catalyze at least in the
molecular dynamics community is - which
is challenged with you know suffers like
many areas with reproducibility we can
actually publish along with our
scientific paper we can publish these
work flow protocols and and hopefully
you know we're trying to develop a
community of researchers who are
developing these
we can all be ensured that we are really
performing research in a transparent and
reproducible way for the maximal game
for for the community and right so when
you're sharing workflow results you
there's different ways that you can you
can share workflows that have with
versioning for example you can use if
you have to do that you cannot there's
also clouds file hosting services so you
can share workflows using Dropbox Google
Drive etc and then the other thing that
we also do and I think a lot of others
have taken to service recently is to
create ipython notebooks that share
execution history input parameters lots
there's many different ways that
workflows can come into the enterprise
and and certainly sharing of the results
is super important okay so only have
five minutes and I want to add these a
couple minutes for questions in case
they're already so but before I leave I
wanted to say this I know this was a
very very high-level introduction to
work flows and pipelines for biomedical
researchers where so if you want to get
more information of course Google as
your friend but I'm gonna just give you
a couple of leads so one place where you
can get some hands-on experience you can
go to bio big data at UCSD done edu
there's a scalable so there is a Kepler
class or course there that is it should
be very easy for people to run it comes
with a virtual machine that you can have
everything all the data and everything
you need installed and lectures you can
actually go to this site and and and
retrieve that information actually go
through the course and if you want to
see this would be the first course is
just on the Kepler frame software
framework if you want to see an actual
application of how workflows can come in
to biomedical research we also have a
class that we call data to structural
models that walks through image analysis
and segmentation
four electron tomography and and it
applies a it applies a coupler workflow
for image segmentation and analysis and
so you can get another certainly more
domain a specific example there and of
course also I need to give a shout out
to erudite and the media 2k training
coordinator coordinating Center they
also I just very quickly search for
workflows in erudite and you can see
that there is 22 different results and a
number of different people who have will
show and talk about examples that that
that highlight workflows in biomedical
research okay and I do have an
acknowledgment slide of course I just
want to thank the efforts that and they
make generally my groups build
high-octane tests actually is my
collaborator Co P I and the bd2k our
twenty five reward for the biomedical
big data training collaborative and she
is she's a major developer of Kepler and
has been a terrific resource for
information on workflows and pipelines
okay so I think I have like two minutes
I would love to take questions if
there's any questions thank you with a
fabulous talk there are a few questions
we have this one is about ring of data
and you mentioned a couple of different
options FTP and SFTP there any others
I'm just internet to improve the
transfer rate on is there anything you
can any advice you can give about about
that speak to yeah so I will say that in
general I we try to avoid moving data
but of course we do have to move some
and that's a very good question
I know that there are other than the
examples that I showed you know I if
this is a tough one for me to answer
yeah we generally we try to avoid moving
huge datasets when we do we just use
sort of like the normal protocols but
definitely I'm
that there are many people who are
working on more effective and efficient
ways to actually transfer data one thing
that we've done to to try to avoid
transferring data of course is try to
work on other technologies like remote
visualization and so forth that's sort
of been our that's been one of our major
efforts okay thank you I think moving
the computation the visualization to the
data is the what what what is more
common now or what will be even even
more common in the future so one more
question what do you think about the
common workflow language and as Kepler
support cwl that's another very good
question I wish ilk I always here to
answer that I'm pretty sure it does I
think a common I generally think how
more for language is it's going to be a
good move for the community I don't know
how when we have actually the heart stop
here I do believe it does support it but
I'm not I'm not sure exactly to what
extent it does I do think we need to
stop now but the thank you very much
Romi this was a wonderful talk and we
really appreciate you coming here and
sharing your expertise with us really
well it was fun thanks all right goodbye
thank you all see you next week